Do you think that doing good theoretical analysis
and doing that in conjunction with the development of algorithms
leads to better, more practical systems?
Yes, of course.
Data sets nowadays are mostly fairly big.
You cannot just rely on hacking to get setups you need.
You really need something which works well in an asymptotic sense.
So, asymptotics is very, very relevant now.
On the other hand, there is a big gap between theory and practice often,
and we really have to close this gap.
It's hard for developers--they don't have the background
and also they don't have the time to read the latest paper
within the time they have to develop a product to implement that.
I think it's very important to come up with algorithms
and investigate their practicality and describe their practical variance.
Do you see that happening by people working in teams?
Or do you think like each individual has to be expert in both
the engineering side and also the analysis.
No, it's best done in teams, because there are some individuals who are good at both,
but in general there are people who are better at inventing new math,
and there are people who are better at engineering new algorithms.
It can be done in teams or also in a process of scientific publication.
Someone publishes their theoretical algorithms,
and then someone else gets a good implementation of it.
For me, algorithms have several components.
There is a mathematical component of algorithms, which is formal analysis of algorithms,
and then there is an engineering aspect where you try to implement
the fastest algorithm you can on a real problem.
I'd like to think the approach which is data-centric method,
which combines the two approaches.
So, you sort of observe the real world and make some computational models,
and then to try to design an algorithm for it and prove some things about it.
Then we implement this algorithm and see if it performs as theory predicts,
and if not, you try to modify the theory and does that explain that behavior
of this algorithm or invent a better algorithm.
How do you even measure the asymptotic running time in practice?
Do you run bigger and bigger random examples? That sort of thing?
It's easy on synthetic data, yeah.
If you have a certain generator which you can set parameters,
then you can measure how an algorithm acts.
On real-world data it's much harder.
Right, because it doesn't necessarily scale in a natural way.
And also for old random examples
there are only two natural examples.
Namely, Europe and North America.